مشاهدينا نستمر واياكم بهذه التغطيه
للكارثه والماساه التي حلت بكل من تركيا
وسوريا والذي تسبب بها هذا الزلزال الذي
ضرب هذين البلدين صباح الاثنين وطبعا
مشاهدينا سنكون مع مراسلينا الموجودين
بجميع المناطق وبمختلف المناطق التركيه
والسوريه لتغطيه هذه الكارثه ونقل صوره
الماساه من هناك
[تصفيق]
يلا روحي يلا يلا وصلنا
[موسيقى]
يلا براءه
يلا يلا
تعال تعال غطيها تعال غطيها تعال
يا تركن يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
وصلت عالدرجه تحت قلبت فينا البنايه انا
من هون من تحت السقف تحتي ضليت كم ساعه
عيط عيط عيط بعدين سكتت اشهدت اخر نفس
واحد لحتى سمعني بس انا شايفه جوزي تحت
السقف وفي اولاد جسس فوقي
في شو اسمه
في اولاد كتير فوقي كانوا
بعدين شو اسمه
جابولي ابني قالوا لي عايش تروح انت تضل
لي واحد تروح
في اخواته
راح ادوس بعد صلاه الفجر
مشاهدينا بعد مرور نحو 90 ساعه على وقوع
هذه الكارثه بدات تتضاءى الفرص الانقاذ
لكن الامل بالمعجزات هو ما يدفع بالمنقذين
للقيام باقصى ما لديهم للعثور على المزيد
من من كتب لهم ومن كتبت لهم الحياه النشات
علهم طبعا يوقفون عداد الضحايا الذي تجاوز
20,500 قتيل على جانبي حدود الزلزال
الحصيله في تركيا وصلت الى اكثر من 16 الف
واكثر من 66 الف مصاب بينما على الجانب
الاخر ونقصد هنا سوريا تجاوز عدد القتلى
الاربعه الاف شخص
عالق تحت الانقاد ربما لم يصدق ما تراه
عينه هل فعلا كتب له عمر جديد فقد حسب
ربما انه سيموت هنا في هذه الزاويه
المظلمه تحت ركامه
تم انقاذ هذا المقيم السوري في تركيا
اطرافه نسيت الحركه حتى تصلبت
جسم مكسر واصوات انين وتاوه كل ذلك قد
يهون الان بعد النجاه
وسط سحابه الحزن العميق التي خيمت على
المكان قد تحمل عمليات انقاذ نبا صارنا
عمليه انقاذ قد تضاه عمليه ميلاد جديده
[تصفيق]
لكن هذه المره ميلاد من رحم المعاناه
انقاذ هذا الطفل كان بالنسبه لوالده هديه
من السماء
فرحه النجاه وان كانت كبيره الا انها لم
تمسح دموع الم وصدمات لن تمحيها الايام
مشاهدينا لنقل الصوره من سوريا وتحديدا من
الشمال السوريه ينضم الينا من معبر باب
الهوى مازن علوش مدير العلاقات الاعلاميه
والمتحدث باسم اداره معبر باب الهوى استاذ
مازن يعني طيله هذا النهار كان هناك
تصريحات للامم المتحده بان اول شحنه
مساعدات وصلت الى سوريا الصوره الاخرى او
الواقعه الاخر يقول بان ما وصل هو
المساعدات الدوريه والعينيه التي عاده
متصل الى هناك هل يمكن ان تشرح لنا بالفعل
ما الذي حصل
مساء الخير لكم المشاهدين طبعا
اليوم هي عباره عن فاصله الشاحنات
المقرره ان تدخل بشكل طبيعي علاقه
باستجابه
ضربه المنطقه هذه الطفله تحتوي على بعض
مستلزمات وبعض
المستلزمات المخيمات اما كاستجابه
[موسيقى]
لم قتل حتى تاريخ لحظه اي شيء ربما غدا
هنالك 14 شاحنه ستصل من الامم المتحده
فيها بعض المستلزمات الخاصه للمنكوبين من
الجذاب اما لتاريخ اللحظه منذ لحظه
حتى تاريخ اللحظه لم يدخل لم يكن لديك اي
استجابه من اي جهه كانت لاهلها
لم يتم
ادخالتي ولا مستشفيات ميدانيه ولا اي شيء
استاذ مازن يعني المطلوب اليوم ليس
مساعدات غذائيه ليس مساعدات عينيه عاديه
التي هي يعني عاده تصل الى الشمال السوري
وليست بالجديد المطلوب اليوم اغاثه معدات
للمساعده على انتشال يعني الامكان الضحايا
وان كان الناجين الذين ما زالوا عالقين
تحت الانقاد يعني الرساله التي توجهها
اليوم للمجتمع الدولي لكل من يسمعنا بهذه
الاثناء
الكريم نوجه رساله الى المجتمع الدولي
بعدم تثبيت المساعدات والنظر بعين واحده
الى جميع المواطنين في هذا العالم مثل ما
هنالك ارسال
مطارات النظام لا تهدا باصول المساعدات
اليه ايضا هنالك اكثر من خمسه مليون مواطن
من المسلمين في منطقه ادلب بحاجه الى
مختلف انواع المساعدات هناك خمسه مليون
مواطن منسوبين على مدار 12 العوامل من
تاريخ الثوره
بحاجه الى كل شيء وزادهم هذا الزلزال
[موسيقى]
يعني مشاكل اكثر ما هم كانوا فيه نحن
بحاجه لكل شيء بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه يؤدي
الى مسافه ميدانيه
متطوع لديهم اجهزه حديثه
للبحث اما كان هنالك حيث تحت الانقاذ نحن
في اليوم الرابع
للزلزال ما زالت لدينا مئات العوائل
العالقه تحت الانقاذ لا لا نعلم اهلهم
احياء المهم اموات
الالياف الثقيله والمعدات بين ايدينا في
قوه مدنيه او في بعض اخرى التي تساعد ليست
كافيه نهائيا لسد الحاجه الكبيره التي نحن
بها للاسف نرى نرى نرى هنالك تثبيت كبير
في المساعدات نرى هناك ازدواجيه المعايير
المناطق النظام الاسد لا تهدا الطائرات
المحمله المختلف دول العالم اليه
نحن ارسلوا لنا اليوم سته شاحنات فيها
مستلزمات نظافه يعني
بالاضافه الى جسامين الشهداء السوريين
الذين
يعني بحسب ما تقول الان هناك شاحنات دخلت
عبر معبر باب الهوى خصوصا ان كان هناك
حديث ان هناك فريق اسباني دخل مع ست
شاحنات اغاثه
الفريق الاسباني دخل
هذا الفريق نفسه مع الاخوه في اداره
الشؤون السياسيه وتم ادخالهم هم الان يكون
طاقه تجهيزات وسيذهبون باتجاه
دخلوا هم دخلوا عبر المنظمات التي تساعد
هناك بمنطقه الشماليه
دخل عن طريق اداره الشؤون السياسيه التي
تمثلنا نحن كمعارضه مناطق
يعني ما ادخلوه بهذه الشاحنات هل هي عباره
عن مساعدات عينيه هل الفريق بدا بالعمل
على الارض وهل تتوقعون وصول او لديكم يعني
معطيات عن وصول
مزيد من الدعم ان كان عبر فرق انقاذ وان
كان عبر معدات
لمساعده بعمليه الحفر
نحن ابوابنا مفتوحه للجميع ونشرنا ارقام
تواصل وحسابات تواصل على مختلف التواصل
الاجتماعي لمن اراد مساعده مرحله من اي
دوله كانت ابوابنا مفتوحه لاستقبال
المساعدات العينيه والماسيه
باي طريقه كانت
الكره الان في ملعب
انتهاء المقابله في حال كانت فرق تريد ان
تدخل الى مواقف المحاضره فنحن مرحبين بها
مستعدين لتقديم كافه التسجيلات لها في حال
كانت تريد ارسال مساعدات ايضا نرحب بها تم
ارسال مساعدات من الجانب السوري اتحدث عن
جانب السلطات الرسميه
من المعروف ان السلطات الرسميه هي التي هي
اصلا تقتل هذا الشعب على مدار 12 عاما على
قلبها ان تقوم نتحدث بالموضوع السياسي انا
اتحدث اليوم عن الناحيه الانسانيه بما ان
كان هناك شروط من بعض الدول وحتى من الامم
المتحده وغيرها بان تكون المساعدات لكل
الشعب السوري وبالتالي هل وصل اي شيء ام
اننا ما زلنا بنفس يعني التموضع الذي كان
موجود سابقا
حتى
اهلنا المقاتلين في منظمهم لم ينصلهم شيء
فكيف يصل لنا نحن
نعارضه المساعدات التي
الارهابيه الموجوده عندهم لا تصل لا
للمواطنين في لاهلنا هناك ولا حتى بالتالي
لن
تصل استاذ مازن كان هناك حديث ايضا عن عزم
السلطات التركيه بتنسيق امم طبعا لفتح
مزيد من المعابر هل هناك اي معطيات حول
هذا الموضوع ما هي هذه المعابر وكيف ستنسق
معكم على معبر باب الهوى
صراحه نحن بالنسبه لهذا الامر كما به من
الاعلام لا يوجد شيء على ارض الواقع نحن
لدينا خمسه معابر مع تركيا
فلسنا بحاجه اصلا لمعابر اخرى مع تركيا
بامكان الامام المتحده اتقان مساعدات من
اي معبر كانت باهلنا
المناطق المحاضره
هي ذريعه شكرا لك استاذ مازن علوش مدير
العلاقات الاعلاميه والمتحدث باسم اداره
معبر باب الهوى على هذه المداخله
زلزال سوريا وتركيا المدمر احد اعنف
الزلازل في العالم واشدها فتكا منذ اكثر
من عقد
الكارثه وقعت فجر الاثنين السادس من
فبراير زلزال بقوه سبع درجات فاصله ثمانيه
ضرب مساحات شاسعه من جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا تسبب بصدع يمتد طوله لما يزيد على
مئه كيلو متر بين الصفيحه الاناضليه
والصفيحه العربيه مركزه كان على بعد 26
كيلومترا تقريبا شرقيه مدينه نورداي
التركيه
[موسيقى]
جميع سكان سوريا وتركيا شعروا بالزلزال
حتى الدول المجاوره لكن اثره المدمر تمركز
في شمال غربي سوريا وتحديدا في محافظات
حلب وحماه واللاذقيه وطرطوس وادلب اما في
تركيا فضرب الزلزال بعنف 10 ولايات وحولها
لمناطق منكوبه
[موسيقى]
بعد 11 دقيقه من الزلزال الاول تعرضت
المنطقه لهزه ارتداديه بلغت قوتها سته
درجات فاصله سبعه
وبعد ساعات وقع زلزال بقوه سبع درجات ونصف
الدرجه تلته هزه اخرى بقوه ست درجات في
فتره ما بعد الظهر
[موسيقى]
حصيله الزلزال العنيف لم تتوقف عن
الارتفاع بين القتلى وجرحه ومفقودين
ومشردين تجاوزت عشرات الالاف في كلا
البلدين عدا عن الاف المنازل والمباني
المدمره
منظمه الصحه العالميه قدرت ان يبلغ 23
مليونا عدد متضررين بالزلزال بينهم نحو
خمسه ملايين من الاكثر ضعفا
وفيما تتلاشى امال العثور على ناجي تحت
الانقاض ووسط طقس صقيعي شديد البروده
تنهمك فرق الاغاثه في البلدين المنكوبين
في عمليات البحث والانقاذ في حين بدات
قوافل المساعدات الدوليه الوصول الى
المناطق المنكوبه ملوك الشيخ العربيه
من دمشق ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر سكايب
ايضا الكاتب الصحفي عبد الحميد توفيق
استاذ عبد الحميد يعني هناك ايضا اسئله
عديده كما في الشمال السوري ايضا في
الداخل السوري المساعدات كيف توزع كيف هو
الواقع الانساني هناك عمليات الاغاثه يعني
هل تتم بالسرعه المطلوبه ام ماذا
مساء الخير لحضرتك والاستاذه المشاهدين في
الحقيقه في الجانب
الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها الدوله السوريه
وفي المحافظات الاربعه التي ذكرت بهذا
الزلزال هناك منذ يوم الاثنين بعد الظهر
بدات القوافل المساعدات عبر الطيران وعبر
البر من العراق ومن الاردن ايضا تصل الى
اتباعا وعافي كل ساعه ربما استطيع القول
بشكل اساعي سواء من الناقلات الناقلات
البريه عبر الاردن بالحدود السوريه
الاردنيه او عبر العراق وكذلك بالطيران
هناك اكثر من اثنتي عشره دوله عربيه ساهمت
برحلات طيران متعدده وصل بعضها الى العشره
رحلات وكذلك هناك من الباكستان وهناك من
الهند وهناك من ارمينيا وهناك من
روسيا وكذلك من ايران المساعدات في
الحقيقه تتنوع على كل الصعد كان هناك اول
فريق مصري من الدفاع المدني كان هناك
دولتان قد رساهمتها
عناصر من الدفاع المدني ومختصون بهذه
القضايا انتشار الجثث او رفع الانقاذ كانت
مصر قد اوفدت منذ الامس وتمكن فريقها
من الدخول او عبور الاراضي السوريه التي
تخضع للدوله السوريه الى بدايه بلده
جنديرس المنكوبه اكثر
قريه او بلده منكوبه في هذا الزلزال الذي
نكب كل تلك المناطق المساعدات حقيقه هناك
بعض الدول التي يوجد في عناصرها موجوده مع
هذه المساعدات ياتي تاتي اتباعا وتوزع
باتجاه المحافظات الاربع بعضها طيران يصل
الى مدينه حلب ويوزع من هناك وبعضها يصل
الى مدينه اللاذقيه ايضا المنكوبه ايضا
بمدينه جبله وايضا عن طريق مطار اللاذقيه
وبعضها عن طريق مطار دمشق وهناك حافلات
بريه توصل هذه المساعدات وهي متنوعه
متخصصه طبيا وصحيا وكذلك متعدده فيما
يتعلق باحتياجات الاساسيه الواقع الحال
بان اساسا الدوله السوريه
ومؤسساتها تعاني نقصا كبيرا في كل
تجهيزاتها بسبب ما مر عليها خلال الاثنتين
عشره سنه الماضيه وبالتالي الامكانيات
محدوده والامكانيات متواضعه ولكن هناك
مساهمات ومحاولات انا استطيع القول بانه
بالامكانيات المتاحه مع رغم الامكانيات
المتاحه المتواضعه ولكن الحقيقه تاخر الكل
المجتمع الدولي يعني بتركيا مع كل
الامكانات مع كل المساعده الدوليه مع كل
الفرق التي وصلت الى هناك وهناك يعني نوع
من التقصير على الارض بسبب هول وحجم
الكارثه هناك بعض المناطق لم تستطع الوصول
اليها حتى الساعه وتمشيطه هل يعني تم تفقد
معظم المناطق والعمل جارم باغلب المناطق
طبعا الخاضعه لسلطه النظام
في الواقع انتشرت هناك عناصر كثيره
ومجموعات كثيره تم اسنادها ايضا من الفرق
العربيه
وقوات الدعم العربيه المدنيه المتخصصه
بهذا الجانب بجانب المدني وكذلك كان هناك
تنسيق من جانب الهلال الاحمر العربي
السوري مع بعض المنظمات الامميه التي هي
موجوده اساسا في الارض السوريه ولم
تغادرها حتى في سنين الاحداث التي مرت
عليها المحاولات كبيره ولكن الامكانات
متواضعه والاياء والساعات واللحظات واليوم
دخلنا في اليوم الرابع وللاسف التقصير
واضحا من كل المجتمع الدولي ومن كل
وتفضلتي بالمقارنه اذا كانت تركيا الدوله
الراسخه المتمكنه ذات الاقتصاد الراسخ ذات
الامكانيات المتميزه وذات القدره الاداريه
على اداره وكوارثها عبد الحميد هناك وضع
خاص اليوم هناك وضع خاص اليوم لل نظام وسط
كل يعني
السرديه السياسيه الموجوده والموقف
السياسي من قبل دول العالم وطبعا لم يكن
محسوب حساب لمثل هكذا كارثه انسانيه
وبالتالي شاهدنا هذا التخبط بالموقف وعدم
يعني عدم المعرفه كيف يمكن التصرف معه
اليوم الفرق التي وصلت المعدات التي وصلت
كل يعني الامكانات التي وصلت لهناك هل هي
كافيه للقيام بما يجب القيام به على الارض
كل ذلك ورغم الامتنان لكل من قدم لكن انا
شخصيا اعتقد بانها غير كافيه على تلبيه
احتياجات التبعات الكارثه ومفرزاتها على
كل الصعد سواء التدميريه بحيث اليوم الى
الان هناك مناطق لم يتمكنوا من رفع
الانقاذ كامله عنها هناك احاديث عن ان
هناك مئات العائلات ربما طمرت ودفنت وحتى
الان الامكانات التي تعمل ربما لم تصل
اليها استاذ عبد الحميد بان هناك اليوم
ايضا صعوبات لوجستيه بسبب يعني حال
الطرقات حال الابنيه حال كل المدن السوريه
بعد يعني عقد من الحرب هذه العقبات
اللوجستيه هل تعيق اليوم ايضا عمليات
الانقاذ
في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها الدوله
السوريه انا اعتقد لا يوجد هناك عقبات على
مستوى ايصال الدعم اللوجستي للمناطق
المتضرره الخاضعه للدوله السوريه لان كل
حتى الضرر الذي اصاب تلك الطرقات على سبيل
المثال اوقفوا من اليوم الاول منذ اليوم
الاول الزلزال يوم الاثنين تم ايقاف
القطارات بين بعض المدن السوريه خشيه من
تصدعات ولكن هذا لا يعني هناك قدره والطرق
سالكه وجيده في الحقيقه باتجاه محافظات
حلب وباتجاه محافظات اللاذقيه وكذلك حماه
وحمص وطرطوس هذه الطرق سالكه
والدعم بالامس كان هناك موكبا كان هناك
موكب لبناني بسيارات عشرات السيارات دخلت
من الاراضي اللبنانيه واتجهت على في البر
باتجاه حماه كذلك بالامس كان هناك ايضا
موكب سيارات من الاردنيين دخلوا ايضا عبر
معبر نصيب باتجاه الطرق سالكه في الحقيقه
ولكن الامكانيات لا تضاهي ولا تستطيع
الاحاطه بحجم الكارثه الكبيره على
المستويات التدميريه وعلى المستويات
الانسانيه وعلى المستويات اللوجستيه شكرا
لك الكاتب الصحفي عبد الحميد توفيق حدثتنا
عبر سكايب من دمشق
مشاهدينا ساتابع واياكم هذا الفيديو الذي
وصلنا قبل قليل لعمليه انتشال طفله قضت
تحت الانقاض حوالي 86 ساعه اذا بعد يعني
اكثر من 80 ساعه تم انقاذ هذه الطفله
البالغه من العمر اربع سنوات اذا فلنتابع
هذه الصور اداره الكوارث والطوارئ الى
توسيع من
طبعا مع كل الظروف الطبيعيه والظروف صعبه
تحت الانقاذ هناك تمات كانت هذه الطفله من
الصمود اكثر من 80 ساعه منذ لحظه وقوع
الزلزال الكارثه الذي ضرب هذه المدن
التركيه
على امل ان نشهد عمليه يعني اغاثه اكثر
واكبر للاطفال الذين
للاسف ما زالوا تحت الانقاض حتى الساعه
بتنامي
سلامتك يا روحي
[موسيقى]
معلش
معلش وانا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من ادلب عبر سكايب
الصحافه مسلم السيد عيسى استاذ مسلم يعني
كنا نتحدث عن الصور ونقل الواقع من معبر
باب الهوى من دمشق ومن المناطق المتضرره
من الشمال السوري في ادلب كيف هو الوضع
الواقع الانساني خصوصا اننا الان دخلنا
بسباق مع الزمن وسباق مع العامل الجوي
الذي يعتبر صعب يعني بساعات الليل خصوصا
في الحقيقه يعني دخلنا تقريبا في اليوم
الخامس على هذه الماساه وما تزال مئات
العوائل ومئات الاشخاص مفقودين تحت انقاذ
منازلهم التي دمرت بفعل هذه الزلازل وقبل
يعني وايضا الردات الاهتزازيه ما تزال
تضرب المنطقه كل ساعه او ساعتين بشكل
متفاوت احيانا متوسطه واحيانا خفيفه وهذا
ما اجبر الاف العوائل الذين لم يتسبب لهم
الزلزال الاول بالضرر بالهرب خوفا وهلعا
الى مناطق مختلفه الى الطرقات العامه الى
الساحات والمساجد وصلاه الرياضيه وغيرها
هناك الاف العوائل يوم تفتقر لادنى مقومات
الحياه البسيطه
البرد القارص حقيقه نحن الان درجات
الحراره تقترب من الصفر في هذه المناطق
بينما فرق الدفاع المدني لم تتوقف خلال
اكثر من 90 ساعه من العمل المتواصل مع فرق
الانقاذ وفرق الكوارث وايضا المنظمات
الانسانيه المحليه على تقديم اقل
الامكانيات المتوفره في الجانب الانساني
المنظمات الانسانيه قالت انها افرغت كل
مستودعاتها الاغافيه بكل ما تحويها قبل
وقوع هذه الكارثه نتيجه الفيضانات والثلوج
التي ضربت المنطقه قبل يوم واحد من هذه
الكارثه وبالتالي هي اليوم تحتاج الى
مساعدات انسانيه عاجله كل ما شاهدناه من
توزيع مساعدات كان بفعل اولا يعني استنفاذ
كل مصادر
ومؤونه هذه المنظمات وايضا المساعدات
الاهليه والمحليه التي تم جمعها اليوم عبر
مكبرات الصوت في المسجد خلفك يعني على ما
يبدو ان هناك مخيمات يعني بالظلمه صعب ان
نميز ولكن هل يمكن ان تنقلنا بالصوره لنرى
هذه المخيمات هل هي هل هذه المخيمات تم
اشاده تشييد الان يعني لايواء العائلات
المتضرره ام انها اصلا كانت موجوده قبل
هذا الزلزال
تماما هذا ما كنت اود التحدث عنه هذه
الخيام انشات اليوم بفعل او او من قبل
المنظمات
عبر الكاميرا عبر زميلي لو تفضل زميلي
صالح ان نرصد هذه الخيار التي تم انشاؤها
على عجاله كما تشاهدون هي موضوعه على
الارض بدون اي مقومات اخرى انشات للناجين
من المكان القريب نحن بالضبط نبعد عن مكان
الكارثه فقط امتار قليله فضل الاهالي ان
ينشئ الخيام بالقرب هذا ما كنت ساساله هل
انشاء هذه المخيمات او الخيم هي من قبل
بمبادرات فرديه بمبادره من قبل الاهالي ام
ان المنظمات غير الحكوميه والاغاثيه ساعدت
بها
تماما هو انشئت هذه طبعا قدمت من المنظمات
الانسانيه المحليه وقالت انها اخر ما تبقى
لديها من مساعدات عاجله سلمت هذه الخيام
ووضعت في هذا المكان بسبب تفضيل الاهالي
ان يبقوا في اماكن الكارثه بانتظار اي خبر
مفرح من المكان الاخر الذي تجري فيه
عمليات الانقاذ تشاهدون ربما في الصوره
النار التي يشعرونها للتدفق عليها
يعني لا يوجد اي امكانيات هنا داخل هذه
القيام وضعت الخيمه بدون اي امكانيات
داخلها تحاول الاهالي جمع بعض الاعواد
الخشبيه وغيرها لتدفئه اطفالها هذه
الاهالي خرجت بدون اي مقومات بدون البسه
بدون اي شيء لانها كانت في منازلها
وبالتالي يعني تحتاج الى كل الاشياء
العاجله اولا التدفئه لاننا كما ذكرت
نقترب من درجات حراره
منخفضه تقريبا الان درجه الحراره قاربت
على الصفر وايضا الاهالي خرج من دون البسه
شتويه بدون البسه للاطفال اما شاهدته
حقيقه كل الاطفال يعني
تتجمد من البرد خرجت بملابسها الخاصه
بالنوم كاطفال وبالتالي ليس لديهم اي
اشياء اخرى تساعدهم على مقاومه هذا البرد
كما ذكرت هنا في هذه المنطقه نتحدث تقريبا
عنه وبالتالي مسلم مسلم هل يمكن القول
يعني اطلاق او مسلم عفوا هل يمكن اطلاق
صرخه بان الاهالي هناك بحاجه لبعض الاغذيه
الاطفال بحاجه لملابس يعني لو سمحت اذا
كان هناك اي حاجه ممكن ان نطلقها اليوم
نعم ساحدد بالضبط ما يعني شاهدته ومعاينته
على ارض الواقع من الاحتياجات الاساسيه
اولا الاهالي تحتاج بشكل عاجل لمواد
التدفئه لانها لا توجد هنا اي مقومات
للدفع كل الاهالي بعشرات المواقع وانت
تكمل لو سمحت هل يمكن ان تكون الصوره على
الخيام يعني ان نشاهدها اكثر
سنحاول عبر الكاميرا نقل ما يحدث من خلفي
هنا كما تشاهدون اولا سنحاول فقط اظهار ان
الاهالي تعتمد على الاخشاب وما يجمعونه من
الاماكن هنا للتدفئه هناك عشرات العوائل
نشاهدها في هذه الجبال تقوم بالتدفئه على
النار التي تشعرها مما تجمعه من الارض
وبالتالي ما الاحتياجات التي كنت تتحدث
عنها
تماما الاحتياجات بالدرجه الاولى مواد
التدفئه ثم ملابس الاطفال الشتويه شاهدنا
كل الاطفال
بالبيجامات وملابس النوم فبالتالي هناك
نقص كبير في ملابس التدفئه والدفء لهذه
العوائل التي فضلت البقاء بالقرب من
منازلها
بانتظار اي خبر عن ذويهم المفقودين تحت
هذه الانقاذ هذه الخيام ايضا تحتاج الى
مطابخ ميدانيه عاجله لتقديم الغذاء لها
لانها لا تملك اي امكانيات ربما لصناعه
الطعام وغيره وايضا لا تملك ايه نقود كل
الاهالي
امكانياتها الماديه وغيرها داخل منازلها
على الشق الاخر تحتاج هذه الاهالي كما
ذكرت السلات الاغاثيه العاجله وايضا مواد
يعني الخيام وغيرها في المرحله اللاحقه
ممكن كما اكدت المنظمات الانسانيه انها
تحتاج لبناء او تقديم الكتل الاسمنتيه
والشقق العاجله ربما لتقديمها من فقد
منزله بشكل كامل اتحدث عن اكثر من 20 الف
عائله هي الان مهجره منهم من تضرر منزله
بشكل كامل على الانقاض ومنهم من تضرر بشكل
جزئي لكن لن تعود هذه الاهالي الى منازلها
وهناك معلومه مهمه من نتحدث عنهم اليوم هم
اصلا نازحون لمرات عديده بفعل تهجيرهم من
قراهم ومنازلهم سابقا والقصف الجوي وغيره
وبالتالي هم فعلا وصلوا الى حد الانهاك
بالكامل يعني هذه العوائل اليوم لا تملك
ايه مقومات اولا ماديه ولا مقومات حياه
يعني فقدوا كل شيء كل مقومات الحياه التي
تلزم لعائله طبيعيه بفعل هذا التهجير
المتتالي مسلم اسمح لي ان اذكر هذا العاجل
الذي ورد الان اعلام النظام السوري يقول
بانه استقبل 40 طائره مساعدات في مطارات
دمشق وحلب والذي قيم
اعود اليكم مسلم
نعم كما تشاهدون يعني نحاول فقط عبر عدسه
الكاميرا اظهار فعلا الماساه لكل مشاهدينا
حتى يشاهدوا فعلا الوضع على ما هو عليه
الان نحن اعيد واكرر نحن الان في منطقه
حارم هي واحده من اكثر من خمسه عشر موقع
في شمال غرب سوريا تم تدمير احياء بالكامل
في هذه البلدات تهجير الاف العوائل وايضا
هنا العوائل من بقي حي يفترش الخيام التي
لا تمتلك ادنى مقومات الحياه البسيطه فيها
اهم شيء يلزم الاهالي الان هو التدفئه
تعتمد الاهالي شاهدنا الكثير من الاطفال
قبل قليل يجمعون اكياس النايلون وايضا
الخردوات والخشب لتدفئه اطفالهم وتدفئه
عوائلهم هذه عينه كما تشاهدونها على عدسه
الكاميرا وما تزال العوائل داخل هذه
الخيام مسلم بعضها في محاوله
يعني من المتوقع ببيانات الارصاد الجويه
بالناحيه التركيه ان تستمر درجات الحراره
بالانخفاض مما طبعا سيعيق عمليات البحث
السريعه
يعني بالشمال السوري كيف هو وضع الارصاد
الجويه والى اي مدى ممكن ان يؤثر على
عمليات الانقاذ اذا ما تدنت الحراره اكثر
باختصار لو سمحت اعتقد انه نعم اعتقد ان
الازمه ستزيد
وستوسع دائره الاحتياجات الانسانيه هنا في
المنطقه نتحدث عن انخفاض بدا في درجات
الحراره نحن يعني وانا بكامل لباسي
الشتويات اهم الحقيقه الوقوف لخمسه دقائق
يعني اظهر الى الكاميرا ثم اعود الى
العربه للتدفئه
لاتمالك نفسه وبالتالي هؤلاء النازحون
والمهجرون من خلفي وهناك الاف العوائل
اليوم فقدت منازلها وبالتالي تحتاج فعلا
وبشكل عاجل لمواد التدفئه بالدرجه الاولى
للمواد الاغ والمطابخ طبعا هي صرخه صرخه
انسانيه خصوصا اننا نتحدث عن عائلات عن
اطفال عن نساء يعني بدون ماوى وبدون ملابس
بهذا الظرف الطبيعي الصعب وبهذا البرد
الصعب شكرا لك مسلم السيد عيسى على هذه
الرساله وعلى هذه الصوره الماساويه التي
نقلت من ادلب شكرا لك
الناس في حاله زور كله تحت الركاب مثل ما
انكم شايفين اجيت هالشباب هاي الموجوده
كلياتها كتفت تساعدت ولكن بالايادي الشخص
بنحتاج لكادرا اكبر ما حدا قصر بس هاي
امكانيات الشعب الموجود الله يكون بالعون
شباب
الله اكبر
سنه 48 ساعه
حجم الكارثه كبير وفي رقمها تقوم بالبحث
الى الان في قريه بسنيا على اخراج
العالقين تحت الانقاض
الساعه 4:12 دقيقه بلشت الهزايه دوب نزلنا
من البنايه وصارت الحياطين تهدم علينا ويا
دوب نفذنا بسابع والناس
بجسمها ونزلنا جوا على البستان تمينا من
الساعه اربعه
للوجه للصبح الساعه تسعه واحنا تحت المطر
وحاليا جينا هنا على المخيم
والله قضينا الليله عند جيراننا بالخيام
بالخيام وغطسنا بالوحل للركب غطسنا يعني
ذبحنا البرد انا والله طالعوني من جوه
الانقاذ
وفيقتني عيلتي البنايه دعت تهز شلت
الويلات رحت الدركض برا شي الحيطه كلها
طفشتني رجعتني على
الغرفه عائلتي نزلت على الدرج هبط عليها
بيت الدرج
واولاد اثنيناتهم بدايه
يعني
اللي صار الزلزال نحن باركين في البيت
نايم ما حسيت الا الارض صارت دقيت
بالاولاد وصرنا نرقد عند الي رقدنا صارت
رجل ارض في زياده اطلعنا والله يعني لله
الامر التدبير طلعنا عراه يعني والله
سترنا اي والله
[موسيقى]
وثق مشاهدينا مقطع فيديو فرق البحث
والانقاذ وهي تخرج طفل يبلغ من العمر عام
ونصف العام من تحت الانقاذ في مدينه هاتاي
بتركيا بعد ثلاثه ايام من وقوع الزلزال
المدمر فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا لنقل الصوره اكثر من على الارض
ينضم الينا من قهرمان مرعش غسان ابو اللوز
مفرد العربيه من يمان موفد العربيه محمود
شكر ومنها طاي موفد العربيه عمار الهندي
عمار يعني ساعيد السؤال الذي سالته بريف
حلب من المتوقع بحسب الارصاد الجويه ان
تتدنى درجات الحراره اكثر بالساعات
المقبله والايام المقبله بان يتشكل جليد
بهذه المناطق التي وقع فيها الزلزال كيف
تتحضر الفرق هناك والى اي مدى ستصعب عمليه
انقاذ وانتشال كل من هم تحت الانقا
الليالي لعلها لعلها المهم جدا يعني هنالك
بصيص امل للتو انبعث من جديد هنا في حيث
اقف في هذه البنايه سمعوا للتو صوت اشخاص
على قيد الحياه في مكانين المكان الاول
هذا الذي يظهر في الشاشه امامك ولزميل
المصور يعني سيحاول الدخول في الكاميرا
اكثر طلبوا من الجميع هنا الصمت مرتين
لانهم سمعوا وتاكدوا ان هنالك احياء فعلا
تحت هذه الانقاض وهذا امر لم يكن متوقعا
بالنسبه بالنسبه لهم لانه كان الحديث بيني
وبينك في المباشر السابق بان عمل الاليات
الكبيره يدل ربما على عدم وجود ناجين
واحياء تحت الانقاض وانها اشاره بان لكل
من تحت هذه الانقاذ يمكن ان يكون قد فارق
الحياه ولكن لا الان هم سمعوا اصوات اناس
تحت الانقاض وبذلك بداوا بالعمل بشكل دقيق
باليات بسيطه في نقطتين النقطه هذه الاولى
والنقطه هناك في في الاخر ايضا سمعوا
اصوات اشخاص اناجين تحت الانقاض وبذلك هذا
امل كبير جدا نحن يعني على وشك ان ننتهي
من اليوم الرابع
ولا تزال هنالك اصوات تصدر من تحت الانقاذ
لاناس اناجين تخيلي هؤلاء لهم اربعه ايام
من دون طعام وغذاء وفي برد قارس وشديد
وتحت الانقاض ويعني
الله اعلم اذا كان احد منهم مصاب او لا
تخيلي ان كانوا هذا امر عظيم وامل كبير
جدا لكل من ينتظر مصير اشخاص تزالوا تحت
الانقاض هذه الساعات الساعات الليل بدات
الان بارده جدا كل المتجمعين هنا من الاسر
انبعث
فيهم الامل ليال من جديد بعد ان طلبت قوات
الانقاذ الصمت لانهم سمعوا صوتا وطلبوا
مره ثانيه وتاكدوا فعلا ان هنالك ناجين
ونتمنى ذلك في كل مكان لا يزال فيه
مفقودين وانا للاسف يعني السؤال الذي
سالتيني اياه في البدايه لم اسمعه كاملا
ولذلك يعني من الحماس والامل الذي اشاهد
وددت ان اتحدث اليك اولا عن وجود ناجين
وسماع اصوات تحت الانقاذ نعم
اسمح لي ان انتقل ساعود اليك على كل حال
ولكن سانتقل الان الى قهرمان مرعيش وغسان
ابو اللوز غسان يعني قهرمان يعني تقريبا
سويت بالارض كيف هي الصوره من هناك
العوائق اللوجستيه التي تعيق عمليات البحث
السباق يعني مع مع الزمن ومع البرد هناك
نعم صحيح بالفعل الوضع صعب جدا في كهرمان
مرعش كون هذا المكان هو مركز الزلزال كما
تعلمين الليال وبالتالي الوضع صعب جدا
الوضع كارثي هي منطقه
منكوبه كما اعلنتها السلطات التركيه
عمليات الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره ومتواصله
حتى هذه اللحظه كما تشاهدينا الان في
الصوره في هذا المبنى ليال يوجد هناك
اشخاص على قيد الحياه كما ابلغنا عناصر من
فرق الانقاذ في هذا المبنى وهم يحاولون
الان الوصول الى هؤلاء الاشخاص الخمسه
واكدوا لنا بان بين هؤلاء الخمسه اشخاص
هناك اطفال
ومقابل هذا المبنى ايضا ليال هناك ايضا
مبنى اخر يوجد فيه ثلاث اشخاص ما زالوا
على قيد الحياه عالقين تحت الانقاذ ايضا
كما اكدوا لنا فرق الانقاذ وما زال العمل
متواصل حتى هذه اللحظه لمحاوله انقاذ
هؤلاء الاشخاص نحن نتحدث الان عن ثمانيه
اشخاص بينهم اطفال موجودين عالقين تحت
بنايتين ما زال العمل متواصل لمحاوله
انقاذهم نحن في شارع في مدينه كهرمان مرعش
فيه عشرات المباني سويت في الارض وهناك
المئات من عمال الانقاذ
المسعفين عمال البحث والانقاذ ما زالوا
يواصلون ساعات العمل
ويواصلونها ليلا ونهارا لمحاوله انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه بعد اربعه ايام ليال اربعه
ايام طويله ساعات طويله على العالقين تحت
الانقاذ وبالتالي هم في صراع مع
الزمن والوقت وليس سباق فقط كلما تقدمت
تقدم الوقت كلما تضاءلت فرص نجاه العالقين
لكن الانباء الساره ايضا تاتي وتنبعث من
بين الانقاذ قبل ساعتين من الان ابلغونا
هنا ايضا انهم تمكنوا من انقاذ سيده من
الانقاض وبالتالي هذا دائما يبعث على
الامل الليال
لمليات والسلطات تؤكد بانها ستواصل هذه
العمليات وايضا
ظهر هذا اليوم عندما وصلنا
في منطقه اخرى كان هناك مبنى من تسعه
طوابق منهار ويوجد فيه خمسه اشخاص داخل
سياره موجودين في كراج للسيارات في ذلك
المبنى
ما زالوا على قيد الحياه تتواصل ايضا
عمليات الانقاذ لكن الوضع صعب جدا عندما
تتحدثين عن مبنى من تسعه او عشره طوابق
منهار بشكل كامل
او الاف الاطنان من الانقاذ عمليات
الانتشار وعمليات البحث هي دقيقه وايضا
تاخذ وقت طويل غسان اسمح لي ان انتقل الى
الزميل محمود شكر من يامان محمود يعني على
امل ان تكون الصوره ايضا ايجابيه من هناك
بظل يعني دخلنا بالساعات الحرجه الان اصبح
السباق والصراع مع الزمن ومع الطقس ومع
الظروف الطبيعيه صعب جدا كيف هي صوره من
اليمن
هنا الصعبه والظروف هي ايضا صعبه جدا
وهنالك سباق مع الزمن كما تفضلت ولكن
الصوره هنا توازي صعوبه والما ومشكله مع
عمليات الانقاذ التي تجري لرفع الانقاذ
الوصول الى الاحياء اذا ذهبنا الى هذه
الصور الحيه للمئات من عائلات النزوح
السوري في هذه المدينه للاطفال الصغار
ايضا وامهاتهم واقاربهم يفترشون الارض في
درجه الحراره تحت الصفر وعدد الصغير من
قطع الخشب على مدار 24 ساعه لربما ان هذه
الصوره التي نحن بها الان مع هؤلاء
الاطفال هذه العائله وايضا مع شقيقه لهم
تعكس هذه الماساه على طول امتداد هذه
البقعه الارض ورائي مباشره يعني مجموعه
كبيره من عائله ايضا حول النار هنا اخذنا
بالصوره مع هذه العائله النساء الصغار
الاطفال اذا خليني بس هيك فقط للصوره نذهب
كيف هم يتجمعون بطانيه لا سقف لهم الا
السماء لا
وساده لهم على الارض او بطانيه الى الارض
كما نشاهد يعني الارض هي مباشره هذه الصور
هي ليست صور يخيل للبعض ربما انها مفتعله
او انها هي حقيقيه هي على مدى اربعه ايام
الى خمسه ايام بالمقلب الاخر كذلك مع
المصور على بعد حوالي 20 الى 40 متر كيف
نجد اذا اذا ذهبنا ايضا هنا الى الخيمه
يعني حاولوا ان يذهبوا او يفروا الى خيمه
فقاموا بانشاء هذه الخيمه والاساس هنا هي
عباره عن تجمع تقريبا نصف متر عن ارتفاع
سطح الارض يبيتون بها الصور مؤلمه محزنه
مع نشاهده من رفع العلاقات والوصول الى
احياء هي بغايه الاهميه ولكن توازيها ايضا
هذه المشاهد الانسانيه لهؤلاء الاطفال كيف
نشاهد هذا الطفل يعني سنتين او ثلاثه قديش
عمره ثلاثه سنين ونص انه هو اللي اليوم
الرابع على هذه الحاله انا لمس ايديك لمس
ايديه
هو بوظ يعني ابوه يقول هو بوص انا لا ادري
كيف انه هؤلاء يستطيعون ان يكملوا في هذه
الايام في هذه الظروف وفي هذا الجو هو
ايضا يبتسم هذه
محمود هل ممكن
ان تسال لماذا لا يوجد هناك خيام هل
السلطات لم تقم بانشاء خيام ما ما الذي
حصل لماذا يباتون هذا هذه الاسئله ساذهب
اليها كل نعم كل هذه الاسئله ولكن قبل ذلك
اعطيني فقط لاكمل الصوره بالمشهديه الى
انه السيارات في الخارج عشرات الان يبيتون
فيها اشرح لي بس شو عم يصير معكم حاليا
وليش انتم اليوم الرابع على هذه الحاله
نحن اول شيء مشكله الدوله التركيه اللي عم
تامرنا مساعدات الاكل والشرب بس نحن يعني
يعني شايف اطفال صغار باعمار ثلاث سنين
واربع سنين وخمس سنين مبوظين
تمام ليش ما عملتوا جهد للحصول على مخيمات
او انتم نشات انتم انشاتوا يعني بدك حل مش
معقوله هذا الوضع يعني معقوله هاي البنت
هيك
يعني احنا بدنا شوادر احنا بنطلب من
الحكومه بس انه بدنا نشادر عليه نحسن نحسن
نعيش فيه يعني احنا ما حدا عم يجي نحن
بدنا ماوى بدنا دفا فقط لا غير رحتوا
ذهبت انت الى السلطات المختصه او كان
هنالك لجنه منكم تعاطت مع البلديه او مع
الحكومه ما في بس عباره عن انه كان
الضابطه تسجيل البوليس يجي احد الاشخاص
المسؤولين عن الدوله كانت تجي انه مثلا
نحن نقول لهم بدنا خيام بدنا شيء تمام
يقعدونا بكره بعد بكره يوم يومين هذا
الشيء اللي عم يصير فقط يجوا مثلا يوزعوا
مي يوزعوا خبز اكثر من هيك ما في بالنسبه
بالنسبه لاذهب الى حالات الذين بقوا تحت
الالقاب او توفوا والاعداد الضحايا
الضحايا تقريبا بما يقارب في اربع خمس
ضحايا هلا تحت الانقاذ بهذا بس هالشعري
هذا ببيعنا واحد فقط بيجي لهون بس بيتطلع
بيقول نحن ما بنحسن ساوي شيء نمشي عدد
الجرحى على الجرحى تقريبا شي 8 اشخاص تسع
اشخاص ببناء واحد تحدث احدهم لا زالت طفله
يجوا لهون
في اشخاص هون موجود الان الان في طفله لحد
الان موجودين لا زالت تحت الارقام في
البلاد تحت الانقاذ البنات موجود طبعا
البنت توفت بيجوا مثلا لهون احنا انه في
عنا اشخاص هون تمام تحت الانقراض نحن ما
بنحسن برايك انه انتم ستستمروا على هذه
الحاله ايام
اكثر
ابني ان كان ابني ولا كل هالاولاد انا عم
بحكي عن كل الاطفال ابني هلا مبوز عمره
ثلاث سنين ونص هذا شو قادر يتحمل بتحمل
اكثر من ثلاثه ايام يومين ثلاثه ما قدر
يتحمل دواء ما في علاج ما في ما ادري انا
عندي زوجتي هلا بالشهر التاسع لازم عنده
حالته ولاده ما عم بحسن باخذها على مشفى
يعني هذا الشيء اللي نحن عم نعاني منه
نعم
على الاقل يعني بطريقه انسانيه تليق
بالانسان هي صرخه محقه اليوم بعد هذه
الكارثه التي حصلت ساعود الى الزميل عمار
عمار الهندي بدقيقه واحده يعني كيف يمكن
وصف الصوره الانسانيه من هاتاي
الصوره الانسانيه من هاتاي محزنه جدا
للغايه
والمدينه منكوبه حقا وتستحق المزيد
والمزيد من الجهود والدعم وكل من يريد ان
يتطوع للعمل عليه ان ياتي الى هنا الى
هاتاي لانه على الاغلب هنالك اعداد كبيره
لا تزال على قيد الحياه لاننا نتفاجئ كل
يوم بان هنالك من يعني يتنفس ويصدر اشارات
ويستغيث من تحت الانقاض كما يحدث هنا في
هذه الصوره ونتمنى طبعا ليال لكل من هم
تحت الانقاذ ان يخرجوا سالمين ونتمنى ايضا
ان تستطيع فرق الانقاذ ان تواصل هذا العمل
الجبار لحين اخراج كل من هم تحت الانقاض
على كل حال يعني عمار سنبقى معك ومع
الزملاء نتابع طيله هذا الليل بهذه
التغطيه المباشره للعربيه لعمليات الانقاذ
على امل ان تكون الصوره ايجابيه طيله هذا
الليل وان يعني تستطيع فراق الانقاذ نجده
اكبر عدد ممكن من المفقودين ومن الاطفال
ومن النساء ومن كل الموجودين تحت الركام
شكرا لك عمار الهندي من هاتاي غسان ابو
اللوز من قهرمان ومحمود شكر من يامان شكرا
لكم مراسلين العربيه طبعا سنكون معكم
بتغطيه لاحقه ضمن هذا النقل المباشر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
هذه العباره تستخدم الان في لحظات سعاده
بانقاذ احد ناجينا من تحت الانقاض او خيبه
امل باستخراج جثه هامده كلا الجسدين
يلتفان بالبطانيات فرق الانقاذ في سوريا
تعمل بكافه طاقتها الاستيعابيه لانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه ازاله الانقاض وتوثيق الضحايا
الا ان نقص المعدات الاكثر اساسيه يجعل
العمليات بدائيه لتكون البطانيات هي
النقالات الوحيده الموجوده في الميدان
وتكون بقايا الملابس الممزقه ضمادات لجراح
بعض الناجين
وضع يتفاقم ويتازم بمرور الوقت فالكارثه
لم تتوقف بتوقف الزلزال بل كل تاخيرا في
وصول المساعدات من المعدات الاساسيه
والطبيه يزيد عدد الضحايا
لتكون مقابل كل ساعه تاخير 50 حاله وفاه
تقول تقديرات فرق الانقاذ الاليات
المتوفره بين يدي فرق الدفاع المدني
المؤديات هي صراحه غير كافيه لحتى حتى
ينجز العمل بشكل سريع وحتى نسحب العالقين
من تحت الانقاض بشكل سريع
الكارثه الطبيعيه التي حلت بالشمال السوري
زادت موتا على الموت الذي يواجهه سكان
المنطقه كل يوم من اوضاع انسانيه صعبه
ثلاث سنين الحرب السوريه الطويله ونزوح
وفقر وحصار وحاجه ملحه مستمره للمساعدات
تضاعفت في ظل زلزال القرن
[موسيقى]
ولم تكن مناطق سيطره النظام في سوريا افضل
حالا ليعترف الاخير ويقر بان البلاد ليست
مهيئه لتبعات هذا النوع من الكوارث وتعاني
نقصا حادا في المعدات اللازمه لرفع
الانقاض والمعدات الطبيه ايضا عمر العربيه
مشاهدينا من الحدود السوريه التركيه ينضم
الينا عمار السلمو المتطوع بالدفاع المدني
السوري عمار يعني الوضع هناك على الارض
الامكانات الموجوده لدى الدفاع المدني هل
تخدم هل انتم امام حاله عجز ام ان يعني
تقومون ما تستطيعون القيام به
اليوم الرابع على الكارثه
عمليات البحث والانقاذ ما زالت مستمره حتى
هذه اللحظه
عشرات الفراق عشرات الفراق تقوم باكثر من
اربعين موقع
باكمال عمليات البحث والانقاذ
اليوم للاسف لم نعثر على لاجين الوقت يبدو
انه تاخر تاخرنا على
الناجون تحت الانقاض ولكن لدينا الامل ما
زال لدينا الامل في العثور على ناجين كما
لدينا الامل في وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
لاستجابه لهذه الكارثه بدانا ايضا اليوم
بدفن الجثث المجهوله الهويه بعد توثيقها
واعطائها ارقام ودفنها
الوضع جدا كارثي ولكن ما زالت الفرق تعمل
باضافتها وبوجود مطوعين مدنيين وايضا
اليات المدنيين نقوم ما نقوم به هناك حاجه
كبيره ايضا للناجون لفتح
لاعاده وصل شبكات المياه
تقديم شبكات الصرف الصحي وصل الكهرباء
هناك اعمال كبيره يجب ان نقوم بها ولكن ما
زال تركيزا الان حتى الان على الوجود على
الوجود على اللاجئين من تحت الانقاب
استخرجنا اليوم عشرات اجهزه من تحت
الانقاظ والعمل ما زال مستمرا ولكن لم يصل
الينا اي مساعده فيما تتعلق بالزلزال يعني
طلبنا منه اليوم الاول بوصول الفرق مع
معدات يعني فرق دوليه مدربه بموادات ولكن
لم يصل اي شيء لذلك اعتمدنا على يعني ما
نمتلك من مصادر محدوده تركمان وحيدين في
مواجهات هذا الزلزال الكبير
مئات المباني ما زالت يعني
مدمره ولم نصل اليها ولكن يعني لدينا الان
في ايجاد ناجين
بالامكانات الموجوده لديكم هل انتم قادرون
نحن الان بسباق مع الزمن ومع الوقت هل
انتم قادرون على انتشار
اغاثه من يجب اغاثتهم ام ان الامل اصبح
ضعيف جدا بسبب ضعف الامكانات
الامل اصبح ضعيف بايجاد ناجين اليوم يعني
اليوم هو اليوم الرابع نحن يعني يعني من
حسب من حسب ما نقوم به سابقا كلنا نقوم
بايجاد يعني ناجون تحت الانقاض بعد ثلاثه
او اربعه ايام نامل ان في ايجاد ناجون
ولكن الامل يتضاءل كل لحظه تاخذ معها جزء
من الامل ولكن هذا الموجود
سنتابع عملنا مع المدنيين في الاخراج اخر
جثه من تحت الرساله التي توجهها اليوم
يعني لكل من يستطيع مساعده الدفاع المدني
بالمناطق الشماليه الحدوديه مع تركيا
باختصار لو سمحت
لا يوجد هناك امل في استجابه دوليه ولا
نوم متحده نتمنى من كل جميع الناس التضامن
وبذل ما يمكن بذله يعني اقل من
الارواح لمساعده الفرق العامله هنا على
الارض في اتمام مهامها النقص شديد نحتاج
كل يد وكل مساعده من اجل اتمام مهام هناك
اناس يستحق يعني يجب ان نستجيب لهم هم
الناجون الموجودين في الطرقات
بدون هؤلاء يعني الحياه ستستمر وهؤلاء
يستحقون المساعده وتجاوز هذه الازمه
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن مساعدات انسانيه
حقيقيه لتامين يعني متطلبات العيش لهؤلاء
لمن نشا من تحت الانقاذ كي ينجوا ويكمل
على قيد الحياه شكرا لك عمار السلمو
المتطوع بالدفاع المدني السوري من الحدود
السوريه التركيه على هذه الرساله
ان شاء الله بعون الله
يا عيني عليك يا بطل يا عبد الحكيم الله
يقويك مشاهدين واياكم طيله هذا الليل
تغطيه العربيه المستمره لكارثه الزلزال
الذي ضرب كل من تركيا وسوريا وطبعا متابعه
عمليات الانقاذ على امل ان يتم انتشال
وانقاذ اكبر عدد ممكن من الناس خصوصا اننا
اصبحنا ودخلنا في الساعات الحرجه بعد
اربعه ايام من وقوع هذه الكارثه التغطيه
مستمره والان الى الزميله راويه